notre premier dossier dioxine seveso
suite
hier nous vous avons présenté la vie à
seveso neuf ans après la fuite de gaz
contenant de la dioxine qui avait
recouvert le petit village italien
nous avons vu que la vie y avait repris
tout à fait normalement
mais ce sont surtout les conséquences de
cette catastrophe écologique sur la
santé des personnes exposées qui pose
encore un certain nombre de questions
dont la question essentielle quel est le
véritable danger que représente cette
dioxine pour les êtres humains
à long terme on aimerait bien sûr après
l'accident de reims être tout à fait
rassuré mais de fait
l'exemple de seveso n'apporte pas de
réponse définitive sur ce point depuis
neuf ans l'hôpital de desio localité
voisine de seveso est chargé du suivi
médical des personnes exposées à des
degrés divers au nuage toxique
au départ on a procédé à un contrôle
systématique dans un rayon de 10
kilomètres autour de l'usiné
onze villages 220 mille habitants
aujourd'hui toutes ces fiches médicales
sont consignés dans cet ordinateur des
archives électroniques grâce auquel il
est possible à tout moment d'observer
l'évolution de l'état de santé de tel ou
tel individu
cependant avec le temps le champ
d'investigation s'est considérablement
réduit aujourd'hui les médecins de
l'hôpital de desio ne contrôle plus que
les personnes à risque elles sont au
nombre de 170 en grande majorité il
s'agit d'ouvriers qui ont travaillé sur
la zone interdite
les jours ni trouve également les
enfants et les quelques adultes qui à
l'époque avait été victime de clarac ni
dans leur cas les examens sont réguliers
et se poursuivront jusqu'en 1999
chaque année ces 170 personnes
contaminés par la dioxine subisse un
check up complet et des contrôles
spécifiques et la toxicologie examens
pulmonaires mais surtout analyses de
sang et d'urines analyse qui permettent
de détecter les anomalies de l'organisme
jusqu'à présent le laboratoire de
l'hôpital l'un des mieux équipées
d'italie depuis la catastrophe de seveso
n'a constaté aucune altération de l'état
de santé de ses patients
ac-v jour neuf ans après
on ne meurt pas plus qu'ailleurs et le
nombre des cancers ni pas plus important
c'est un premier constat mais prudence
il est encore impossible aujourd'hui de
prévoir à long terme les effets de la
dioxine
ces effets pervers on les étudie dans un
autre laboratoire celui de l'institut de
recherche pharmacologique de milan
l'institut mario negri dirigée par le
professeur gara qui nous l'un des
spécialistes mondiaux de la toxicologie
ici en a créé depuis l'explosion de
seveso une cellule de crise
cet appareil le spectromètre de masse
est capable de détecter la plus infimes
traces de dioxine dans notre
environnement et dans l'organisme
jusqu au milliardième de mg dans ce
laboratoire
on a également réalisé des expériences
de toxicité sur les animaux résultat 2
kg de dioxine peuvent tuer 50 milliards
de cobaye
il s'agit bien sûr d'une statistique
mais cela démontre que la substance est
très dangereux par discussion sur le
fait qu'il s'agit de matériel toxiques
il via le discussion sur le fait que pas
tous les espèces sont également
sensibles par exemple le chêne semble
être moins sensible que le rat ou le
cobaye
mais la sage est relativement sensible
et pas l'homme l'homme on ne sépare car
on n'a pas encore des données
définitives sur l'exposition de leurs
mains dans les différents incidents qui
sont arrivés et on n'a pas encore tous
leurs données comme gély faut atteindre
certains effets sur l'organisme mais
également sur le terrain dans le cas de
seveso l'institut mario negri a procédé
à plus de 5000 analyses afin d'évaluer
la diffusion et degré de concentration
de ce puissant toxiques sur
l'environnement c'est à partir de ces
résultats que l'on a pu mesurer la
réelle ampleur de la catastrophe et
déterminer le type de dioxine contenue
dans le nuage 2vic mesa autre constat
chaque incident de ce genre peut
engendrer une substance différentes
prince n'échappe pas à la reine à rien
s'il ya surtout
bazot furane pour les chlorures et il
faut dire par exemple que l'athée tracts
le tpr accords libano furane est moins
toxiques
succédant détermination que la structure
du bateau dioxyde donc il ya une
différence qualitative dans des
composants chimiques qui sont en jeu en
ce qui concerne les composants
quantitative
j'ai l'impression que il y a des
quantités qui sont comparables à la zone
contaminée de ce biseau cents à fait
d'accord avec les analyses du professeur
pas oui je pense que c'est très
difficile de discuter les analyses de
monsieur rap qui est un des compétences
internationales que il nous a aidés
aussi pour la faire c'est désolant
je pense que en lui il avait il est
selon le chercheur qui a les moyens
meilleur danalyse de ce type de
contaminer les autres différences encore
d'un procédé au rm c'est que à seveso la
biotine est arrivé par l'extérieur sur
les maisons et dans les maisons
c'était juillet donc il y avait les yeux
ouverts
les fenêtres étaient provocants ouvert
et tout le matériel entrées tandis que
même si le matériel est entrée par
l'intérieur ça j'y pense devrait
simplifier le problème de la
décontamination par rapport à la sphère
du fiso la catastrophe écologique de
seveso doit nous permettre de tirer au
moins deux enseignements d'abord qu'il
ne faut pas jouer aux apprentis sorciers
avec une substance dont on ne mesure pas
les conséquences
ensuite il faut agir avec une extrême
prudence après l'incident les
importantes mesures de sécurité prises
par les italiens ont parfois été jugée
excessive mais c'est peut-être grâce à
ses infinies précautions qu'on a évité
le pire